hey everyone welcome to this session by
simply learn in this video we dive
deeper into our PA by creating and
executing a simple bot so let's go ahead
and look at what's in store for us we
will cover topics like yrb what is RP
what is not RP
how does RP a work RP a software tools
what is uipath UI pop components and a
simple hands-on demo so by exactly RP a
now consider a tech support unit there
are dresses hundreds of queries on the
daily their job is to mainly guide the
customer to the appropriate take you net
to help resolve the issues now most of
the work that they do is basically
strenuous repetitive and monotonous and
not to mention time-consuming
now RP can diminish the workload of the
human helpdesk by automating
straightforward and definitive tasks
complex administrative tasks like fault
remediation and regular Diagnostics can
also be automated
all in all RP a reduces human workload
and implements tasks effectively and
efficiently so moving on to the most
important question what exactly is RP a
robotic process automation is the use of
software with artificial intelligence
and machine learning capabilities to
handle high-volume repeated tasks that
previously required humans to perform
now some of these tasks could be
addressing queries making complex
calculations maintenance of records or
even maintenance or transactions now to
give you a better understanding let's
look at an example consider the
onboarding of a recruit into an IT
company data collection is a crucial
part of the process with that
information a new user account email
address and access rights are generated
with robotic process automation the user
account in automatically activate a
template for the onboarding workflow now
RPA can assess prepare create new joinee
data initiate meaning of offer letters
and streamline the entire information
across the systems so tasks that
previously required asked to perform can
now be done within a few seconds with
the help of RP stats show that RP a
automation and accuracy can be
he's 200% and the processing speed can
be made ten times faster our PA tools
that uipath and blue prism among others
are now being deployed at top IT firms
so when you hear the term robotic in RP
it's legit to assume that it involves
robots that perform human tasks while
this is partially true there are certain
misconceptions so what are they so what
is not RPM RB bots are not humanoid
robots they do not have a physical form
unlike robots like Sophia these BOTS can
not entirely replace humans they are
self control and monitored by us and
lastly they do not possess human
cognitive skills the lack logical
thinking and cannot make decisions on
their own which by extension makes them
incapable of replacing humans now that
we have a clear understanding of what RP
is and what it's not you must be
wondering how it works so let's have a
closer look at its working the first
step towards any approach is planning in
this stage the processes to be automated
are defined which includes identifying
the test objects finalizing an
implementation approach and defining a
clear roadmap for the RPI implementation
next we have design and development as
the name suggests in this phase you
start developing the automation
workflows as per the agreed plan
third is deployment and testing this
phase typically includes the execution
of the bots now any expected outages are
to be taken care of during the
deployment to ensure accurate
functioning testing of these bots for
bugs and errors is crucial lastly is
support and maintenance now providing
constant support helps in identifying
and rectifying the errors better moving
on we have our PA software tools now
these tools typically help develop and
execute BOTS some of the RPE tools are
uipath blue prism automation anywhere
rock fusion among others in this
tutorial we will execute a bot using the
UI path tool before executing a demo
test case let's go ahead and understand
what UI path is and its interface UI
path is basically an advanced or PA tool
which allows you to create control and
execute front office and back office
BOTS with the help of visual templates
and die
rooms now it also provides into an
automation calling it hyper automation
uipath offers three different product
suites first up we have UI path studio
now it is a platform to create
automation BOTS it encompasses hundreds
of activity templates and ready-made
components to drag-and-drop now some of
his features include GUI dashboard which
basically consists of activities like
send email display message and so on it
offers different types of recorders to
record user actions or multiple
platforms it provides logging and
exception handling he also has reusable
components now the user can create these
reusable components to publish them
together as libraries the next product
suite is uipath robot now they run
automation bots that are created using
UI path studio there are different types
of robots firstly we have the attended
robots now these robots work with you to
speed up the service desk and the help
desk it's basically used in activities
where human involvement is key next up
we have Arden attended robots now they
operate without the human touch
maximizing the cost and performance
benefits for any variety of back-office
tasks the third product suite is the
orchestrator now it is a centralized
robot management dashboard where you can
easily deploy secure and manage your
uipath robots at scale now here's the
course of action the first step is that
the user creates a bot next the user has
to save this project and which is later
used as a process now once the process
is created it is assigned to a specific
robot to execute it this collectively
constitutes a job and all of which is
taken care of by the UI path
Orchestrator now let's understand the UI
path interface in brief first up we have
the recorder now as the name suggests
this component allows the user to record
all user actions such as navigations
clicks etc next up is scraping now it
involves two components one is the
screen scraping which is the
programmatic collection of visual data
and the other one is data scraping which
is the extraction of structured data
from an application user events now all
mouse clicks and keystrokes given by the
user as input are recorded using this
feature lastly we have variables now
variables are used primarily for using
certain features now these variables
hold different types of data and can
change over time alright now that we
have a
understanding of uipath let's go ahead
and execute a simple test case so here's
what we're going to be doing first we
extract information about books on the
website that is goodreads.com so what
information on the extracting so we're
going to be extracting the names and the
authors of the new released books then
this information is going to be stored
in an excel sheet and this excel sheet
is going to be sent over an email so
let's go ahead and execute the test case
all right so let's go ahead and open
your iPad studio and here you go and
click on new process in the top right
corner alright and we provide a name for
it say our PA and I say create so now
this is going to create a workspace for
you this might take up a few seconds and
this is what the typical uipath studio
interface looks like
so moving ahead we need to create a
sequence of activities so for that let's
go ahead and say new sequence with the
top left corner and provide a name for
it I choose to keep it sequence so I say
create but what exactly is a sequence
now sequence is a set of activities so
all the activities mentioned in a
sequence are executed in the same order
all right so now in our use case we are
going to be scraping data from the
goodreads.com website right okay so now
we'll have to navigate to the
goodreads.com website and I've opened it
in my browser so here we navigated to
the most popular books published in
March 2020 so now I have to extract data
from this right I need two fields
basically I need the name of the book
and the author all right so what we're
going to do is you go back to your iPad
studio and click on data scraping so go
ahead and click on data scraping and
here it is open your browser or
application and wherever you want to
extract your data from and then we click
on next and then click on the field that
you want to select
so I say next and here I want just the
name right so I click on the name and it
says you've selected an entire table
cell would you like to extract the data
from the whole table no I just want the
name of the table right so I say no
and now the next thing you need to do is
you have to create a pattern the tool
needs to understand what exactly you are
extracting so what we do is we have to
create the pattern to do that we have to
select a second element so I say next
again I must click on the second name
here
I say click and now the name of the
column that I want to give so I say
books and I say next now so this is how
it's going to look this is the data
preview right so next we need the name
of the author
so I say extract correlated data here so
go ahead and click on that and now I
need the name so I say I click on Suraj
a mass and again to create a pattern I
need to select another element so I say
next and click on the next name of the
author so I click on this and I give the
name author for this column alright so I
click on next ok so this is how it's
going to look so after this I say finish
all right
so now it's going to ask me if data is
panning across multiple pages now in our
case if you look at this page data is
not spanning across multiple pages say
suppose you had one two three four five
saying there are more books ahead then
that would be data spanning across
multiple pages so that is not the case
here so I say no in our case and that is
it so we have scraped that data from the
website okay so now that we're done with
data scraping the information that has
been extracted has to be saved in a CSV
file so for that you have to create the
file so go to your activities and say
write CSV all right so just drag and
drop the activity here now it asks for
two fields right so the first one is a
target field where the information is
stored so provide a name for it for that
let's go ahead and browse it and in my
case I create a document say demo one
underscore RPE
and save it alright and the next field
is a write from field now the
information that you're storing in this
CSV file is basically the output of data
scraping so that is all the information
from the data scraping event is stored
in an output variable so click on that
and here you see you have an output
variable so copy the output variable
control C and then paste it here all
right now save the file and now let's
execute it to see if it successfully
works so go ahead and click on play
so alright I've completed the execution
so let's go ahead and check if it has
completed the execution correctly so I
go back to my documents uipath and we
have demo one underscore RTA open that
and here we go we have the name of the
author and the book all right so this
works completely fine okay so the next
step in our use case is to attach the
CSV file and send over an email now for
that you have to provide your
credentials that is your email ID and
the password now these credentials are
also used multiple times across the test
case so instead of specifying it every
time we can create variables right one
for the email ID and one for the
password so for that click on variables
here and say create variable and okay we
have one already here so let's call it
email and the other one is called
password so go ahead and provide your
credentials
so I provide my email id
and then my password
okay and then save it alright now we
have to attach this CSV file and send
over an email right for that we have an
activity called send SMTP mail message
so go ahead and drag and drop it here
and now it has three fields it has the
two field
the subject field and the body field
right so two is where you provide the
email ID so here I'll just say email
because I've already defined a variable
the next of the subject so I say
attachment and say the body a key I'll
keep it simple and say PFE okay now we
have to attach the file alright so click
on attach files and here we have to
provide the path to the file so go back
to the place where you've saved your CSV
file and copy the path and paste it here
as an expression and at the end you
provide the name of the file so it was
demo one underscore RP a dot CSV okay so
now go ahead click on OK now we have a
lot of other fields to provide here as
well so here we have the port field
now the SMTV port that we using is
number four six five so go ahead and
provide that and the server is basically
smtp.gmail.com alright and again we have
to provide the email ids that is just
email and this is just password
and then to is also provided already and
the sender is again me so I say email
again and the password is again password
alright so now save it okay and as you
can see there are no errors that means
it's good to go okay so let's go ahead
and execute this and see if it executes
successfully so go ahead and execute it
alright so it has successfully finished
its execution so now let's go to my
gmail account and see if I've received
any mail and yes I have so go ahead and
click on that and here I download the
file and see if it's appropriately sent
and here we go so here we go we have the
name of the book and the author ok so
with this we've successfully implemented
an RPA bought for email automation now
uipath also offers so many features that
you can play around with to create more
advanced RPA BOTS so I hope you found
this video helpful thank you for being
here keep learning and stay tuned to
simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here hi there if you like this
video subscribe to the simple learn
youtube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here